the biggest problem with men today is
that I think the world is becoming hyper
competitive most men are not aware and
understanding of how quickly there's
going to be a genuine shift in between
those who have things and those who do
not have things not just finances but
also females status everything else and
it's a status game right and it's
becoming harder and harder for men to
play and that's all women's fault of
course
because nobody is because women choose
the winners right women choose who the
high status males are so women pretend
to give a [ __ ] about men of course they
don't they give a [ __ ] about themselves
and and and a woman and a woman and a
woman a woman if you ask her what she
wants from a man she's like I don't want
much I just want to find a nice man
who's a millionaire and six foot tall
and funny and charismatic and
interesting and spontaneous and looks
after me and doesn't cheat and and it's
funny and good looking and strong I
don't want much like they name all this
[ __ ] that most dudes are never gonna
have